LAWMAKERS STOP PROTECTING THE
LAWBREAKERS AND START PROTECTING
US, AND THAT'S THE "ANGLE" ."
JOINING ME NOW FOR REACTION IS
LIEUTENANT BRIAN McGREGOR WITH
A POLICE DEPARTMENT.
HE IS INVESTIGATING THE
ATTEMPTED KIDNAPPING INCIDENT
INVOLVING AN ILLEGAL ALIEN WITH
A MACHETE AT THAT WALMART THAT
WE JUST TOLD YOU ABOUT.
AND IN ALABAMA, THE SISTER OF
AMY HAWKINS, WHO WE JUST TOLD IT
WAS ALLEGEDLY KILLED BY AN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT, JOSE LUIS
ALONSO-DE LEON, AS SHE WAS
CYCLING.
AND BALDWIN COUNTY ALABAMA D.A.,
WHO IS PROSECUTING
MS. HAWKINS' ALLEGED KILLER.
LET'S START WITH YOU, THIS BROKE
MY HEART TO HEAR THIS STORY
COMING OUT OF ALABAMA.
I ACTUALLY LEARNED ABOUT IT
BECAUSE ONE OF MY RADIO
LISTENERS CALLED IN TO MY SHOW
AND SAID A COLLEAGUE OF HIS IS
THE ACTUAL HUSBAND OF THE VICTIM
IN THIS CASE, AND THAT HE WAS
DISTRAUGHT AND DEVASTATED.
I LOOKED IT UP AND INDEED THIS
HAPPENED.
TELL US ABOUT THIS CASE AND ANY
MORE DETAILS THAT YOU HAVE
DISCOVERED.
>> LAURA, THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US ON TONIGHT, AND AS FOR YOU
AND YOUR LISTENERS, PLEASE PRAY
FOR AMY HAWKINS' FAMILY AS THEY
GO THROUGH THIS TRAGIC TIME.
IT SEEMS THAT ON SUNDAY AT ABOUT
12:25:00 P.M., AMY HAWKINS WAS
RIDING HER BICYCLE ON ONE OF OUR
ROADS ON THE EASTERN SHORE NEAR
FAIRHOPE AND DAPHNE, AND SHE WAS
NORTHBOUND, AND THE DEFENDANT IN
THE CASE, JOSE LUIS
ALONSO-DE LEON, WAS HEADING
SOUTHBOUND.
HE SWERVED AROUND THE CAR TO
PASS AND STRUCK MS. HAWKINS, WHO
IS RIDING A BICYCLE.
HE DID NOT STOP, AND CONTINUED
ON, AND WAS FOUND A COUPLE OF
MILES AWAY SEVERAL MINUTES LATER
MILES AWAY SEVERAL MINUTES LATE.
HE WAS HIGHLY INTOXICATED AT
THAT TIME WHEN HE WAS ARRESTED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY ALSO FOUND A STOLEN PISTOL
IN THE VEHICLE.
WE THEN HAVE LEARNED, THROUGH
CHECKING, THAT HE HAS AT LEAST
SEVEN ALIASES AND, ACCORDING TO
I.C.E., IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT,
HE WAS DEPORTED TWICE DURING
2014.
IT IS A TRAGEDY THAT --
>> Laura: SHOULD NEVER HAVE
HAPPENED.
THIS SHOULD NEVER HAVE HAPPENED.
SANDY, THIS IS YOUR SISTER.
I CANNOT IMAGINE WHAT YOU ARE
GOING THROUGH AT THIS MOMENT,
AND IT SOUNDS HOLLOW TO SAY
THAT, BUT I AM PRAYING FOR YOU
AND YOUR FAMILY AND EVERYTHING
THAT YOU HAVE GONE THROUGH, AND
HER TWO CHILDREN, HER HUSBAND,
HER ENTIRE FAMILY, YOU.
IF THIS THING COULD HAVE BEEN
VETTED AND HE COULD'VE BEEN
PREVENTED FROM COMING INTO THIS
COUNTRY, WHETHER THROUGH A
PHYSICAL BARRIER OR THROUGH
EFFECTIVE DEPORTATION, I MEAN,
YOUR SISTER WOULD BE ALIVE.
WORDS DON'T EVEN CONVEY -- I AM
FURIOUS ABOUT THESE CASES, AND I
AM SADDENED AND AS DEVASTATED AS
I COULD BE WITHOUT HAVING KNOWN
YOUR SISTER.
>> YES, MA'AM.
SHE WAS A BEAUTIFUL SISTER.
SHE WAS A GREAT MOTHER, A GREAT
DAUGHTER.
IT IS A TRAGEDY.
>> Laura: KNOWING THAT THIS IS
AN ILLEGAL ALIEN WITH SEVEN
ALIASES.
THEY ARE TRYING TO TRACK DOWN
HIS CRIMINAL HISTORY NOW, AND
I'M SURE MR. WILTERS, YOU'LL BE
DOING THAT, OTHER CRIMES HE
COULD HAVE COMMITTED, A STOLEN G
COULD HAVE COMMITTED, A STOLEN N
COULD HAVE COMMITTED, A STOLEN I
COULD HAVE COMMITTED, A STOLEN
COULD HAVE COMMITTED, A STOLEN S
COULD HAVE COMMITTED, A STOLEN P
COULD HAVE COMMITTED, A STOLEN E
COULD HAVE COMMITTED, A STOLEN S
COULD HAVE COMMITTED, A STOLEN O
COULD HAVE VERY WELL GONE ON, IF
HE HASN'T ALREADY BEEN
COMMITTING VIOLENT ACTS AGAINST
OTHER PEOPLE, AND IT WAS YOUR
SISTER'S DEATH AT HIS HANDS THAT
CAUSED HIS ULTIMATE APPREHENSION
CAUSED HIS ULTIMATE APPREHENSIO
APPREHENSION, AND I ASSUME WILL
BE PUT AWAY FOR A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME.
FURTHER THOUGHTS ON THE FACT
THAT THIS GOVERNMENT WAS UNABLE
TO KEEP THEM OUT OF THE COUNTRY?
>> LAURA, IT'S A TRAGEDY.
>> Laura: SANDY?
>> GO AHEAD, SANDY.
>> IT IS A TRAGEDY.
NOTHING IS GOING TO REPLACE MY
SISTER.
I DON'T HAVE THE ANSWERS TO
THAT.
I LOVED HER.
AND, YES, HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED.
SOMEHOW.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY THAT
HE WASN'T ABLE TO DRIVE A
VEHICLE, THAT HE WASN'T ABLE TO
DRIVE DRUNK.
I DON'T HAVE THE ANSWERS TO THAT
RIGHT NOW.
I KNOW MY FAMILY IS HURTING OVER
THE WHOLE SITUATION.
>> Laura: LET'S TALK TO
LIEUTENANT McGREGOR.
THE REASON I WANTED TO BRING
THESE STORIES TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE'S ATTENTION TONIGHT,
LIEUTENANT McGREGOR, THESE
AREN'T JUST NAMES ON A PIECE OF
PAPER, THESE AMERICANS ARE
PERSONALLY DEVASTATED BY THIS
TYPE OF CRIME, AND WE ALMOST HAD
ANOTHER SITUATION UNFOLD IN
KENNER, LOUISIANA, ABOUT 6 MILES
FROM NEW ORLEANS, AND ONE OF OUR
CONTRIBUTORS HERE FROM
NEW ORLEANS, HE BROUGHT THIS TO
MY ATTENTION, GOT A GUY WITH A
MACHETE IN A WALMART TRYING TO
KIDNAP A LITTLE 2-YEAR-OLD.
HE GOES ON TO TRY TO KIDNAP
SOMEONE ELSE, ANOTHER PERSON,
AND HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THIS IS MADNESS.
LIEUTENANT?
LIEUTENANT McGREGOR, YOUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT THIS CASE NOW AS
IT STANDS?
HOW DID HE GET INTO THIS
COUNTRY?
HE WAS DEPORTED TWICE, AT LEAST,
WE UNDERSTAND?
>> THERE ARE STILL THINGS WE ARE
LOOKING INTO.
WE KNOW ON FRIDAY AT 2:00 P.M.,
HE ENTERED WALMART THROUGH THE
GARDEN CENTER AND APPROACH THE
DELI SECTION OF THE STORE.
HE ENGAGED A FEMALE THAT HAD A
2-YEAR-OLD IN A GROCERY CART AND
HE THREATENED THAT FEMALE.
HE ALSO THREATENED THE LIFE OF
THE CHILD AS WELL AND HE ALSO
PUT HIS HAND ON HIS SIDE TO
INDICATE THAT HE HAD A MACHETE
ON HIS SIDE.
THAT FEMALE ASKED FOR HELP.
HE REACHED TO GRAB THAT CHILD
AND, LIKE ANY MOTHER WOULD, SHE
FOUGHT FOR HER CHILD AND GRABBED
THE CHILD FROM THE CART AND
PROCEEDED TO GET THAT CHILD ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT DELI
COUNTER.
SOME WALMART EMPLOYEES AS WELL
AS CITIZENS AND EVERYBODY ELSE
THAT ENGAGE THE SUSPECT, HE RAN
BACK TO THE MEAT AND POULTRY
SECTION OF THE STORE.
HE DREW THE MACHETE.
HE SWUNG IT AT EMPLOYEES WHO
CREATE A DISTANCE, WHICH ALLOWED
HIM TO GET BACK INTO THE DELI
SECTION WHERE ANOTHER MOTHER WHO
WAS COMING THROUGH WITH EIGHT
INFANTS STRAPPED TO THE GROCERY
CART, HE TRIED TO GRAB THAT
CHILD WHILE HE WAS STILL HOLDING
THE MACHETE.
LIKE ANY OTHER MOTHER WOULD, SHE
FOUGHT FOR HER CHILD AS WELL.
AN EMPLOYEE THAT WAS THERE, AND
A POLICE OFFICER THAT WAS OFF
DUTY, TO ENGAGE THE SUSPECT, GOT
HIM DOWN ON THE GROUND,
HANDCUFFED HIM, TOOK HIM INTO
CUSTODY.
>> Laura: THAT'S GREAT.
THOSE WALMART EMPLOYEES AND THE
OFF-DUTY OFFICER TACKLED HIM,
ULTIMATELY WALKING INTO A
WALMART WITH A MACHETE.
LIEUTENANT McGREGOR, YOU ALSO
WORKED ON A CASE THREE YEARS
AGO, AS I SEEM TO RECALL,
INVOLVING EIGHT -- I THINK IT
WAS A HERMAN RIVERA WHO RAPED A
10-YEAR-OLD GIRL?
WAS THAT YOU ON THAT CASE?
>> I HAVE HAD MANY CASES.
WE JUST FINISHED UP A MURDER
WITH A DISMEMBERMENT.
IF YOU LOOK ON THE NEWS, IT WAS
JUST RECENTLY REPORTED THAT WE
HAVE A CONVICTION OF
SECOND-DEGREE MURDER IN ADDITION
TO OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE, A
MURDER THAT HAPPENED HERE IN
KENNER WHERE A INDIVIDUAL'S BODY
WAS CUT UP AND DISMEMBERED AND
THROWN INTO ST. JOHN'S PARIS PAR
THROWN INTO ST. JOHN'S PARIS PAS
THROWN INTO ST. JOHN'S PARIS PA.
>> Laura: IT'S A VERY SAFE
COMMUNITY, FOR THE MOST PART,
VERY SAFE RETENTION, KEEPING THE
COMMUNITY SAFE, AND THE
COMMUNITY IN ALABAMA WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT, ALSO A VERY SAFE
COMMUNITY.
BUT NEW ORLEANS ITSELF IS A
SANCTUARY CITY, CORRECT?
AND YOU HAVE BLEED THROUGH FROM
NEW ORLEANS INTO YOUR COMMUNITY?
YOU'VE GOT PEOPLE WORRIED ABOUT
TEARING DOWN STATUES IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT, BUT
MEANWHILE, WORRIED ABOUT MAKING
THEIR WAY INTO THE COMMUNITY.
I WANT TO ASK BOTH OF YOU, LAW
ENFORCEMENT, HOW IMPORTANT IS
THAT FOR LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO
COOPERATE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON THIS IMMIGRATION
ISSUE AND TO GET THESE PEOPLE
IMPRISONED AND THEN OUT OF THE
COUNTRY.
WE'LL GO BACK TO YOU,
MR. WILTERS.
>> WELL, IT'S VERY IMPORTANT,
LAURA.
AND IN THE LAST YEAR, THERE HAS
BEEN TREMENDOUS COOPERATION
BETWEEN LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES
WHERE, FOR EIGHT YEARS, WE
DIDN'T HAVE IT.
HAVING THE KNOWLEDGE THAT WE CAN
CONTACT I.C.E. AND THAT I.C.E.
WILL ACTUALLY COME IN AND PLACE
A DETAINER ON AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT HELPS US TREMENDOUSLY.
THERE ARE STILL SOME MARKINGS
AND AT THAT HAVE TO BE WORKED
OUT, BUT THE COOPERATION WE'VE
HAD IN THE LAST YEAR HAS JUST
BEEN TREMENDOUS.
>> Laura: WELL, WE HAVE ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES IN THE UNITED STATES
THAT ARE REFUSING TO COOPERATE.
THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
REFUSING TO COOPERATE,
ENDANGERING THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS, INDIVIDUALS IN THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY, VIOLENT
CRIMINALS ARE RELEASED, THEY GO
ON, AND THEY CREATE MORE HAVOC
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
I WANT TO CLOSE WITH SANDY.
SANDY, IF YOU COULD SAY ANYTHING
TO, YOU KNOW, IMMIGRATION
OFFICIALS, THE GOVERNMENT, GIVEN
THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE LOST YOUR
SISTER JUST A FEW DAYS AGO, OUT
FOR A BEAUTIFUL BIKE RIDE ON A
BEAUTIFUL DAY, SHE SHOULD BE
HERE ENJOYING HER FAMILY
TONIGHT.
SHE WAS AN INCREDIBLE PERSON.
AS AN AMERICAN CITIZEN, WHAT
WOULD YOU SAY?
>> LET'S FIGURE A WAY OUT TO FIX
THE SYSTEM.
WE NEED TO FIX THE SYSTEM.
SO
THAT THESE TYPE OF TRAGEDIES
DON'T HAPPEN TO OTHER FAMILIES.
>> Laura: SANDY, GOD BLESS
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON THE SHOW
TONIGHT.
I KNOW IT WAS REALLY HARD, AND I
KNOW OUR VIEWERS REALLY ARE
PRAYING FOR YOU AND YOUR FAMILY,
AND THANK YOU.
THANK ALL OF YOU.
LAW ENFORCEMENT, D8S, YOU GUYS
HAVE A LOT OF HARD WORK TO DO